ha habido varios reveses para el
mandatario el más reciente fue que el
senado hundió su plan de reforma al
sistema electoral y hay otros factores
como la retirada de afganistán que son
muy cuestionados esta baja en la
favorabilidad le puede jugar en contra y
hacer que pierda el control de las
cámaras que los demócratas pierdan el
control de las cámaras en las elecciones
de medio término
sí bueno buenas tardes definitivamente
con ese bajo popularidad y con los
reversos que ha sucedido con el señor
baile el control de los demócratas de la
cámara de representantes está en peligro
normalmente el partido que está en poder
va a perder escaños en las elecciones se
llaman meterme y en este año es casi
seguro que los republicanos van a tomar
control de la cámara de representantes
la cuestión es que si los demócratas
pueden mantener control sobre el senado
si pueden mantener ese lado tienen mayor
chance de avanzar con uno de los
proyectos de opaín si pierden ambos
casas va a ser muy difícil para el
presidente cuáles son los principales
retos que le esperan al jefe de estado
para 2022
definitivamente el primero es la
economía y la inflación el pueblo
americano ve todos los días en los
supermercados en las estaciones de
gasolina y en el alquiler de las casas
un aumento y eso siempre va a causar
problemas para un mandatario él tiene
que tomar control sobre eso empezando
aflojando las cadenas de suministro está
restringiendo mucho la economía y
causando la pasión también el
resurgimiento de comida de un pacto
grande él tiene que ir y tomar control
sobre eso y con empezando a bajar las
esencias y las pantallas de omicron hay
señales que él puede hacer eso
finalmente yo bailé fue elegido porque
él dijo que puede hacer cosas que tenía
una historia en el senado de los eeuu
que muestra que él es capaz de manejar
el gobierno y lograr objetivos él ha
tenido unos reversas muy dramáticas y
muy públicas en el congreso él tiene que
volver
a tener proyectos prácticos que pueden
recibir el apoyo de ambas cámaras en el
congreso y así se puede tener unos
logros aunque no tan grandes y masivos
como él quería
unos logros prácticos y mostrar que él
sí tiene control sobre la situación